The hardest thing for me is that
I never got to say goodbye
to my old life.
I was an avid rock climber.
I worked out every day.
I ate extremely healthy.
There was really nothing
that I could have done
to prevent what happened
a little over a year ago.
I was hospitalized with COVID
I was born with aortic valve stenosis.
I wasn't able to do sports at all.
I wasn't really allowed
to do a lot of workouts
I wasn't allowed to run.
So with my heart,
it did make it a little bit worse.
I flatlined three times a quickly.
My state started to become really bad.
I found to psychosis.
I had my legs amputated.
I lost £70 because I wasn't able to eat
or drink
There were certain,
you know,
life support systems that they couldn't
put me on because of my heart.
I was in the hospital
recovering for two months in a day.
I mean, there were
some days that I was like,
oh, you know, in a year I'll be good.
But most days I was like,
I don't even know if I'm going to make
it till tomorrow.
Normally it will take
more energy to walk
with prosthetics than not.
I did it.
And on top
of not having any muscle to begin with,
it was just overexerting
and my heart
not being taught to your condition.
It just made everyday
activities extremely difficult to do
It takes
three months
post-surgery to be fully recovered.
This will actually be the first time
that I can run
long distance or trains for that period.
Go.
I'll be able to climb
proficiently post-COVID
for the first time. Got it clear.
So I have finally
able to start modeling again.
When I look at the pictures,
i see the beauty.
I see the
the strength, the resilience,
and that ain't gonna take.
No.
I definitely looked back
on my old pictures and I would 100%
compare them to now.
It's kind of hard to not.
But then I remember
I look at like Aimee Mullins
and you heard the word Wasser,
and I'm like, well, they look great.
I mean, there's only one way to go
and it's forward.
Can't really go anywhere else and.